μέρα με χαμόγελος στη δουλιά και οργανισμός φροντίζειπάντα πρέπει να φροντίζει νανα δημιουργά αυτόν το
χαμόγελο την ίδια ώραν ο κόσμος χρειάζεται ο κόσμος τη σίτα χρειάζεται ν οργανισμόν επιτυχημένο
διότι τον καιρότηση διοδιηοποίησεις που συζητεί το ιδρηγοποίηση ο κόσμος έβλεπε ότι πλέον το μέλλον
του δεν είναι εξασφαλισμένα γι αυτό και πολύ εφευγαντότε πότοποποβό να χάσουν οφελήματα γι ότι
διποέφυγε περίπου το εποσπέτσ εκατόν του κόσμου τη σίδατοτετ ο πότε νομίζω έχει καταλάβει μετά
από αυτή την εμπηρία το προσωπηκό της ίδα ότι πρέπει ο οργανισμός να παραμείνει επιτυχημένος
και κάνει ότι μπορεί το προσωπικό και πραγματικά τους ευχαριστώ για τα τελευταία πεντε χρόνια
για να παραμείνουμε σε αυτή την μπορεί αν επιτυχίας και έτσι βλέπουν και αυτή ότι
αν οργανισμό ενεπιτυχημένς δίννει και πίσω στον κόσμο αυτά που θέλει αυτό είναι μια ισοροποία
επίσεης που εμείς σαδιεύθυση την έχουμε σαν κόρι ενο φθαλμό δεν προσπαθούμε δηλαδή να από
μιζήσουμε από τον κόσμο ούτε όμως δίνουμε στον κόσμον οφελήματα για να φανό μας τε
εμείς ωραίοι τα οποία οφελήματα δεν τα κερδίζουμ με την προσφοράν τους δις συνδέουμε τις
αμιβές και το αφελήματα του κόσμου με την προσφοράνουναιτο σύστημα να ξιολόγηέβαια κάτι που στο
δημόσιο δεν υπάρχει δεν υπήρχε μεχρι τώρα έχουμε βάλει από το δύο χιλιάδες ίκοση σύστημα
να ξιολόγησης που πλέο δεν είναι όλι άριστη ο πότε ο καθένας παίρνει αυτό που
του αξίζει και αρχίζουμε και συνδέουμε χρηματικές και μία μηβές με αυτή την αξιολόγηση δηλαδή
προαγωγές αυτή τη στιγμή στη σίδα δεν εξαρτόνται από το πιον ξέρεις υποσοχς ε ποιον
κόμμανήσε υπόσον παλιώσεισεείσε πια συντεχνί ανισ εξααυτόνται από το πόσον καλώς είσαι γι αυτή τη
θέση που θες να διεκδηγήσεις και αυτό είναι κάι το οποίον είμαστε περήφανει που το
έχουμε ιοθεησης